. Hallo Köln! Das geht Köln! Wow! Dankeschön! Schönen Abend! Vielen Dank! Ey, das ist eigentlich... Du musst keine Angst haben, nee, du musst keine Angst haben. Dankeschön. Wir haben gesagt, das ist deine Bühnenseite, das ist meine Seite.
Du musst keine Angst haben, nein, klopfen Sie, vielen Dank. Ey, du brauchst keine Angst haben. Dankeschön. Wir haben gesagt, das ist deine Spünenseite, das ist meine Seite. Du brauchst keine Angst haben, nein, klommen Sie, es geht. Die Leute haben sich extra da drüben hingesetzt, damit sie dich sehen können, also komm jetzt hier nicht rüber. Denn natürlich seid ihr nur gekommen, um den einzigen wahren zu sehen, und heute ist er hier fantastisch. Das freut mich jetzt Stefan Tietze! Und kein geringerer Co-Host ist heute am Start. Er hat sich nicht lumpen lassen. Das ist Florentin Böhle! Ach, ist doch gut. Dankeschön. Dankeschön. Aber natürlich am allerwichtigsten, ihr seid da, das freut uns sehr. Viereinhalb Jahre, nachdem ihr die Tickets gekauft habt, damals ... Ja, zwei Jahre später. Das ist kein Scheiss. Diese Tour hat noch das andere Poster gehabt. Rein nach Inflation habt ihr ein Vermögen bezahlt damals. Heute wäre das sportbillig gewesen. Moment, das muss ich jetzt kurz nochmal, da habe ich jetzt Knot im Kopf. Nee, nee, die haben viel weniger gezahlt, richtig? Aber Geld war ja auch, das verstehe ich immer nicht, weil Geld war ja auch weniger wert. So, dann heisst die Tickets waren auch weniger wert, heisst ihr habt im Endeffekt ratio mässig genauso viel gezahlt wie damals. Ich glaube, damals hätte man so vier Kilo Bananen bekommen und die sind heute auch weniger wert. Also das ist glaube ich so die Umrede. Für vierzig D-mal. Für acht Monate Jamba-Spar-Abo habt ihr damals in den späten 1990ern, als diese Tour ursprünglich stattfinden sollte, deswegen auch nicht verwirrt sein, wenn heute die Referenzen ein bisschen daneben sind. Aber kein Problem. Kein Problem. Aber es hat wirklich jemand geschrieben, ob wir ihm helfen können, weil er sein Ticket nicht mehr gefunden hat. Und das ist ja auch eigentlich meine Angst. Ja klar. Ich fände nicht so schlimm, dass die Tour verschoben wird. Ich liebe Verschiebungen. Also wenn du nächste Woche was vorhast und dann kommt so ein Termin näher und dann verschiebt jemand was. Yes! Oh, können wir da mal eine ehrliche Umfrage machen? Wer von euch, als er erfahren hat, dass die Tour verschoben hat, wurde, hat sich ein bisschen gefreut. Komm, komm, komm, komm, komm, komm. Ja, ja, aufzeigen. Da sind Leute dabei. Ja, also das glaube ich nicht, dass es nur zwei sind. Warum, weil du was Besseres vorhattest? Es war noch sehr warm im Mai. Jetzt habe ich schon wieder einen Toten im Kopf, Florian. Jetzt musst du mir nochmal helfen. Also, die Inflation im Mai? Im Mai war die damalige Temperatur noch sehr heiß im Vergleich zu heute. Das heißt, du hast gesagt, heute ist schön warm, heute würde ich gerne drausgehen, aber leider ist heute Podcast-UFO. Und als dann leider in den neuen Uhr Nachrichten kam, muss abgesagt werden, hast du gesagt, yes, schöner, was hast du an dem warmen Maiabend gemacht vor viereinhalb Jahren? Ah, okay, vergessen, so toll kann es dann doch nicht gewesen sein. Aber auch gut, wenn man sich freut, dass im Mai die Tour abgesagt wird, dann freut man sich, weil es dann da zu warm wäre und dann wurde sie verlegt auf den 26. April. Man denkt so, ja, ich habe ein bisschen bekommen, wofür ich gehofft habe. Ich freue mich immer, wenn Sachen abgesagt werden. Ich muss immer meine grössten, Oscar-würdigsten Leistungen da reinstecken, wenn jemand sagt, wir haben uns jetzt doch entschieden, am Wochenende die Kanutour. Das ist einfach zu weit und der Fluss ist zu stark. Zu stark. Es war eine blöde Idee, in die entgegensetzte Richtung zu fahren. Das war dumm, wir haben das durchgerechnet, die Arme sind zu klein, man kann gar nicht so schnell rudern. Und ich so, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja. Das sind alles gute Argumente. Ja, und wir haben nur drei Helme für fünf Leute. Und dann die Nachricht, deswegen haben wir uns überlegt, wir verschieben uns um eine Woche. Ach ja, da ist es leider warm, da muss ich leider etwas tun, was ich sofort wieder vergesse. Aber auch gut ist für uns zu wissen, laut an uns, lass uns keine Tour mehr machen, wenn es zu warm ist. Ja, nein, aufgleich. Weil das wollen Leute nicht, Leute kommen da nicht hin. Wir machen die Podcast-Ufo-Apris-Ski-Tour, da gibt es dann schön Glühwein, schön unten, ihr könnt dann irgendwie schön nachmittags hochfahren auf den Gipfel, dann schön runterfahren und abends ist dann die Show oben im Erdgeschoss, wo sagt man, im, wie sagt man, im Erdgeschoss, im Tief... Tal. Tal, danke, gut. Wunderbar, danke schön. Das habe ich mir eingefallen, zu mir selber eingefallen. Aber ist denn derjenige da, der sein Ticket verloren hat? Jonas war glaube ich der Name.
Hat er es geschafft hier heute? Hat die … Haha, Jonas ist da, weil du das Ticket wieder gefunden hast, weil der Veranstalter geholfen hat. Ah, okay. Der Ticket ist noch nicht aufgetaucht. Aber du hattest das Ticket und hast es leider verloren. Wie muss man sich das vorstellen, du hattest das Ticket im Briefkasten und bist dann damit
fröhlich durch die Gegend gelaufen und dann plötzlich, ah, wo ist es hin oder wie ist das genau? Oder er ist direkt zum Mülleimer gelaufen. Wo hast du es als letztes gesehen? Was war der letzte Ort, wo du dein Ticket gesehen hast? Ich hasse das. Gar keine Erinnerung. In der vorletzten Oh, okay. Köln, ne, auch ein bisschen. Der Immobilienmagnat, das war 2011, das war so vor vier, fünf Wohnungen. Einfach mal so, das glaube ich. Aber ich glaube auch, dass du das Wort Immobilienmagnat falsch benutzt, wenn du das Gefühl hast, die ziehen sehr, sehr häufig um. Am ersten Sagen, sag mal bitte, was du glaubst, was Immimm auf die Hände. Es bleibt unter uns, aber ich habe keine Ahnung, was das Wort Magnat hat. Es hat irgendwas mit Magneten zu tun, aber Magneten, Magnat. Magnat ist ein grosser Magnet. Aber was haben wir eigentlich für Highspeed-Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer, oder? Letzte Show dieses Jahr, ja, meine Ex-Freundin, bei ihm jetzt die vorvorletzte Wohnung. Wie schnell lebt ihr eigentlich? Es gibt mir auch das Gefühl, viel zu langsam zu leben und ich dachte immer, ich lebe zu schnell.
Nein, ihr lebt viel zu schnell, ganz hibbelig sitzt ihr alle da und sagt, ich muss umziehen, ich muss umziehen, ich muss Schluss machen, ich muss heute noch zweimal Schluss machen und zweimal eine neue Beziehung starten, das geht alles schnell. Sag mal so die Top-Drei-Orte, an denen du es vermutest.
Auf Platz drei der Plätze, wo Jonas, richtig?
Nice.
Vermutet, dass sein Ticket liegt.
Platz drei der Plätze, wo Jonas, richtig, vermutet, dass sein Ticket liegt. Platz drei. Einfach so schnell sagen. Nicht nachdenken. Fensterbank. Fensterbank, oh, sehr gefährlich, da ein Ticket abzulegen. Einfach so da, wo ich jeden Tag lüfte. Einfach wieder schön die Fensterbank. Da kommen schon jetzt die ersten Theorien durch, wie es verloren gegangen sein könnte. Ganz kurze Frage nochmal an den Raum. Ist denn jemand mit dem Ticket von Jonas hier? Also musste jemand beim Eingang sagen, ja hallo, ich würde gerne vorne sitzen, bitte. Es ist freier Platzwarten. Ach so, ja klar. Also die klassische Jonas-Imitation machen, weil irgendwo muss das Ticket ja sein. Dinge, die verloren gegangen sind, alles, was ihr je in eurem Leben verloren habt, ist irgendwo jetzt. Jede Socke, jedes Halsband, jeder Arm reif, jedes Knöchel, Knöckchen. Ich habe mal damals von meinem Cousin ein Tetris-Spiel geschenkt bekommen, äh, geliehen bekommen. Quasi dasselbe. Ist gleich wie Gold für mich. Geliehen plus Cousin ist gleich geschenkt. Ja, das habe ich mir auch gedacht. Wir alle kennen die Regeln. Habe ich geliehen bekommen und es war damals noch für diesen dicken Gameboy-Color und ich habe das irgendwo einfach verloren in meiner Wohnung und er wollte das wieder haben und ich sehe ihn nicht so häufig, ihm so zweimal im Jahr und ich wusste, ich muss es bis zu diesem Tag x finden und habe es nicht gefunden. Und dieser Stress, der da auf einem liegt, mir konnte kein Veranstalter, worum das heißen soll, helfen, sondern ich musste dann einfach suchen, habe es nicht gefunden und habe es dann neu gekauft. Ich habe es neu gekauft und ihm dann geschenkt und gesagt, ich habe leider alle deine Speicherstände gelöscht und ich glaube, es ist noch nicht aufgeflogen. Ich glaube, es ist noch nicht aufgeflogen. Ich habe es ganz toll sauber gemacht. Du hast dann extra so Kaffee drüber gekippt und so durch den Sandkasten geworfen, damit es so Abnutzung gespürt wird. Seitdem denken die, ich habe so einen Putzfimmel, weil ich komme nicht mit diesen ekligen kleinen Disketten klar. Ich glaube, das ist das Netteste, was ihr jemals für seinen Cousin gemacht habt, oder? Cousins sind doch so... Du hast doch mal Cousins. Oh, okay. Cousins? Für die mache ich sehr viele nette Sachen. Wirklich? Nein. Ich dachte, Cousin ist so Verwandtschaft auf Probe, so mal, manchmal so, aber ist nicht so ganz ernst. Wir reden noch von Cousins, ne? Cousins. Ne, Cousins. Okay. Ja, wie die Stefanseite, man sieht einfach, der Saal ist genau gespalten. Die Leute, die sich auf meine Seite setzen, sagen Cousin, richtig? Nein, okay. Naja, aber eher zürgerlich, ehrlich gesagt. Behemendes Kopfschütteln in der ersten Reihe, okay. Immer die Meinungsstärksten in der ersten Reihe, vor allem die acht hier, die haben es richtig. Aber das finde ich so lustig, weil das ist the most German view, dass man einfach hier vorne einfach eine leere erste Reihe hat und dahinter ist eigentlich alles voll, was ich schon krass finde, weil wir so viele Nachrichten bekommen haben, dass wegen Corona-Ticket abzugeben sind. Aber hier die ersten acht haben es nicht geschafft.
Ja, die Leute denken immer so, ah, wenn ich mich nicht in die erste Reihe setze, werde ich nicht auf die Bühne geholt.
Aber falsch gedacht.
Reihe zwei, here we go!
Wir haben einige Verlosungen, Tombolas und wir haben brennenden Reifen backstage.
Einer von euch darf durchspringen.
Du hast mir gesagt, ich darf durchspringen.
Du darfst danach auch durchspringen, okay?
Ich will als erster durchspringen. Das ist aber ein Sicherheitsrisiko. Es liegt dafür eine Currywurst in der ersten Reihe. Nachos. Nachos? Oh, okay. Meine Augen wären auch echt schlecht, ey. In der ersten Reihe kann ich das Gericht nicht mehr erkennen. Hast du gesehen, dass es Nachos sind? Ist das so der neue Augenarzt-Test, dass man sagt, so welches Gericht ist es, wenn du sagst Currywurst Brille! Moment, ich war noch nie beim Augenarzt, ich glaube so. Wie glaubst du reagiert der? Ich sag, ich glaube, dass die Variante zwei ein bisschen besser ist. Brille! Ich denke, der Augenarzt, der hatte die Lösung, der spick dann so und denkt nicht so, come on, come on. Aber du hast recht, Augenärzte, ich war beim Optiker, weil die haben ja was davon, wenn man eine Brille bekommt. Ja klar. Die wollen doch, deswegen geht doch nicht zu einem Optiker für einen Sehtest, weil die wollen doch, dass sie die Brille bekommt. Die haben die ganzen Tricks drauf, die wackeln da mit diesem Poster, ist das ein bisschen verschwommen gerade, ein bisschen verschwommen gerade, Brille, Brille. Und dann, fiel man, Brille. Und dann, viel man, Brille!
Und dann aber auch, wenn man dann ganz nah rangeht an diesen Augentest, ist es auch immer noch verschwommen, wenn man ganz nah rangeht.
Ja.
Und dann wird man so, ja, aber Leute, das ist doch offensichtlich ein Fake, ihr wollt doch mit der Brillen verkaufen.
Also, das sehen Sie da noch verschwommen auf die Distanz, Herr Thielsen, Sie brauchen definitiv eine Brille!
Aber ganz kurz, erste Reihe, sitzt niemand, nur eine Currywurst, vielleicht ist das ja der Grund, warum da niemand sitzt, weil du deine Nachos dahin stellst.
Vielen Dank. Aber ganz kurz, erste Reihe, sitzt niemand, nur ne Currywurst, vielleicht ist das ja der Grund, warum da niemand sitzt, weil du deine Nachos dahin stellst. Ach, man kann nicht sehen, das Problem. Wer kann mich jetzt noch sehen? Nee, aber wie lange ziehen wir das durch? Du, solange es sein muss. Ich finde das okay. Vor allem das Lustige ist ja, dass die uns ja normalerweise bei Folgen auch nicht sehen. Ja, absolut. Also warum wollt ihr uns denn jetzt sehen? Es ist auch nicht so, dass wir irgendwie optisch irgendwelche Tricks mit Feuerreifen vorbereitet hätten. Ja, es ist absoluter Quatsch. Und vor allem jetzt hat auch mal die oberen Ränge... Haha, der Trottel ist dein Handy aus der Tasche gefahren. Oh nein, ich muss wieder zurück. Kommen wir zurück. Jetzt haben endlich auch die oberen Ränge mal ein bisschen eine gute Chance, oder? Ach, scheiße. Wo sind die oberen Ränge? Scheiße, die habe ich vergessen, als ich mich dusselig auf die Bühne gelegt habe. Ihr seid die Schiedsrichter so ein bisschen. Ihr sitzt oben und ihr habt so ein bisschen den Schiedsrichterposten wie beim Tennis oder beim Minigolf oder Golf oder keine Ahnung. Beim Minigolf, ja. Beim Minigolf hast du ganz weit weg, ganz oben. Auf so einem Kran. Weil für die anderen ist es nicht mini genug, deswegen geht es nicht ganz weit oben hin, um auf ein noch kleineres Feld zu gucken. Hat sich da schon mal jemand beschwert, Entschuldigung, wir spielen jetzt seit einer Stunde auf dem Minigolfplatz und uns ist das nicht klein genug. Schauen Sie sich mal diese Mühle an. Ich kann da ja fast reingehen. Gucken Sie mal, meine Frau passt da rein. Okay, okay, okay. Für diesen Fall haben wir, kommen Sie mal mit, haben wir hier noch diese B-Halle. Das ist für alle, die sich beschweren, dass Halle A zu klein ist. Ja, die ist ja super. Kommen Sie da mal rein, so und wenn Sie, wenn wir hier drin sind, so jetzt gucken Sie sich da mal die kleinen Bahnen. Das ist genau das Richtige für mich.
Das ist genau das Richtige.
Und wenn Ihnen das noch ein bisschen zu gross ist, dann folgen Sie mir.
Okay, ja, okay, interessant, dass sich so viele Leute beschweren.
Ja, das ist immer nervig.
Oder, falls Ihnen das noch so klein ist, können Sie auch auf diese vierzig Meter hohen Türme gehen. Dann erscheint alles ganz automatisch ganz klein. Ihr braucht auch ganz lange Schläger von da oben, damit ihr von oben noch mitspielen könnt mit so ganz langen Minigolfschlägen. Ich wollte unbedingt mal Ringrichter, nee, das heisst nicht Ringrichter, Kortrichter beim Tennis sein. Wie heisst das? Schiedsrichter. Ist doch mega geil, da oben und guckst die ganze Zeit runter und so und irgendwann rufst du Sachen wie 2015. Aber ich will dir nicht zu nahe treten, aber meinst du, dein Nacken hält das aus? Nein, also ich glaube, mein Nacken hält das, wenn ich sitze den ganzen Tag, schon nicht aus. Vielleicht ist es aber ein besseres Gegenprogramm, wenn ich so.
Wohingegen, wenn du minutenlang immer hin und her gucken musst, kann nicht einer einmal, zweimal hintereinander schießen, muss nicht mehr abwechseln, so ist es glaube ich sau anstrengend, einfach immer hin und her.
Aber das geilste, die geilsten Schiedsrichterberufe finde ich ja beim Skispringen, weil da war eine sehr lustige Reportage jetzt, als die Winterspiele in China waren, über ein, weil immer das Gastgeberland stellt auch einen Schiedsrichter beim Skispringen, weil die bewerten ja auch den Sprung. Und dann gibt es immer fünf Schiedsrichter aus fünf Ländern und das Mittel wird genommen, immer die mittleren drei glaube ich werden genommen für das Endvoting. Das heisst, wenn ein Deutscher springt und du hast einen deutschen Schiedsrichter, gibt er tausend, ich weiß nicht, wo die Grenze ist. Direkt gestürzt, direkt auf dem, ja zehn, für mich war das eine klare, zehn, zehn, zehn. Es geht ja darum, wie er gefallen ist. Genau, dass er beide Ski gleichzeitig verloren hat, das hat mich gepackt. Das war ästhetisch schön. Wenn die sich so erklären müssten, immer so, ja das war toll, das war richtig schön. Und das Problem war, da musste halt China so einen Schiedsrichter stellen, aber die hatten keinen im Land, weil Skispringen keine Sportart ist, was Chinesen praktizieren. Und dann hat irgendjemand, dann haben die einen Grundschullehrer genommen, so einen Grundschulsportlehrer und haben denen so ein Seminar geschickt, kein Scheiß, das wird nicht passiert, und haben den dann zu den Olympischen Spielen geschickt und haben den da zum Schiedsrichter, bis dahin ausgebildet, in so einem VHS-Crash-Kurs. Stell dich vor, du bist ja auserwählte, so wir brauchen sie, unser Land braucht sie. Okay, was muss ich tun? Was muss ich, ja folgendes. Ich bin bereit, ich bin bereit, alles zu geben, meine Familie zu verlassen, ich tue alles. Vielen Dank erstmal für Ihr Engagement, fürs Vaterland. Brauchen Sie meine Leber, meine Organe, meine Lunge? Wir haben was ganz Besonderes. Ich bin bereit für alles, egal was da kommt. Sind Sie bereit? Ja. Eine richtige Heldentat müssen Sie vollbringen fürs Land. Zu allem bereit für mein Land, ja. Sie werden der erste chinesische Schiedsrichter für Skispring. Ach komm schon! Ich will doch nicht Schiedsrichter werden. Für Skispring. Wir brauchen Sie. Aber ich dachte auch, man nimmt dann einfach so einen Schiedsrichter aus einer Ans Sportart. Man einfach sagt so, ja, nimm den Minigolf-Schiedsrichter, so das passt schon, der kriegt es dann hin. Der kriegt es schon hin. Die sind ja bestimmt auch immer vom Fernseher zu Hause und klug scheissen richtig hart, obwohl sie der falsche Schiedsrichter sind. Und dann sagt er immer, Heinrich, jetzt du bist Minigolf-Schiedsrichter, jetzt reichst dich mal zusammen, okay? Du hast Grenzen, du hast Grenzen. Grösse, vor allem in der Grösse. Nee, und dann hat er den Job ganz gut gemacht. Er war dann sehr stolz. Nach deiner Meinung nach. Nee, weil, wie gesagt, es werden immer die drei Mittleren genommen, und er wollte halt dann, er hat auch ganz klar gesagt, dass sehr viel Druck da jetzt drauf ist, weil er will halt nicht einer von den beiden Äusseren sein, weil er will halt nicht der sein, wo alle sagen, es war offensichtlich eine 15 und er gibt nur 89 und alle sagen, Entschuldigung, was ist das für ein Schiedsrichter, aber habt ihr den ausgegraben? Das sind Grundschullehrer. So, und deswegen wurde er nicht auffallen, aber er hat es dann gut hingekriegt, er ist verschmolzen. Ich war auch mal in der Jury für Poetry Slams und genau nach dem gleichen System fünf Juroren Das klingt mir grau nach der gleichen Schiedsprenger. Fünf Juroren, die schlechteste Wertung und die beste Wertung fliegt raus und meine Wertung ist jedes Mal rausgeflogen, weil sie die schlechteste war. Echt? Ja, und man am Ende einfach sagen müsste, okay, du magst einfach keinen Poetry Slam. Du bist einfach, das ist nicht so, dass das schlecht war, du magst einfach nicht so. Wir sind gekommen, um zu sehen, das Leben zu erleben, uns selbst eine neue Chance zu geben, sich anders zu sehen, die Flügel aufzuspannen, alles andere für uns zu nehmen. Zwei von zehn, raus! Zwei von zehn. Aber der Beste. Ja, aber wir sind vereint im Hass auf Poetry Slam. Ich glaube, es hat sich langsam auch angekommen, dass es allgemein gehasst wird, glaube ich. Ja, wurde auch abgeschafft einigermaßen, oder nicht? Ich habe jetzt lange nichts mehr mitbekommen von Poetry Slammern. Und die berühmten Poetry Slammern machen inzwischen Podcasts wie wir. Ja, das stimmt. Vielleicht machen wir bald Poetry Slam. Nein, ruft jemand. Nein, sagt er, doch dein Nein ist mein Ja, ich tue was ich will, nicht was ihr von mir wollt. Es ist auch nicht schwer, man muss einfach nur reden, als könnte man die Sprache nicht so richtig. Ja, ja, genau. In einem falschen Momenten ausmachen. Ja, die Pause, das dachte ich gerade, wie genial, was eine geniale Beobachtung ist, aber die Pause in einem falschen Moment ist. Aber deswegen, ich habe es aufgehört, Juror zu sein, und seitdem wurde ich nie wieder gefragt, irgendwas zu bewerten. Was schade ist, weil ich gerne bewerte, bewerte sehr, sehr gerne. Okay. Aber sehr niedrig, sehr hart. Okay. Will jemand was vorführen, was Florian denn dann bewerten kann? Hat jemand einen kleinen Limerick geschrieben. Und da gibt es ein Elfchen, gibt es ein Elfchen unter euch? Wir wissen, dass unsere Community sehr elfchenaffin ist. Hier war gerade der Herr, es war die erste Äußerung des Publikums wirklich über Poetry Slam. Sekunde, wir haben hier gerade jemanden. Ja. Sie möchte nur Ihre Photoshop. Oh, sehr gerne. Ah ja, guck mal, er kann eine Photoshop sehen. Oh, vielen Dank, okay. Ja, eher mästig. So, ich halte das mal hoch, damit es alle sehen können. Sehr gut. Ist schön, okay. Publikum ist bitte begeistert. Also vom Publikum her ist es eine zweieinhalb von zehn gerade. Okay, wir sehen hier das klassische Bild aus den Simpsons, wo Homer am Ende auf das Bild schaut. Do it for her, mit den ganzen Bildern von Maggie.
Und das sind alles Bilder von mir in meinen dunkelsten Momenten.
In meinen dunkelsten Momenten, ich einmal als Heavy-Metal-Katze, dann ich als Meerjungfrau, wow, okay.
Das ist aber, dir ist schon klar, dass Dinge unter Wasser breiter aussehen, das ist eine Lichtbrechung, das ist bekannt. Und du weisst auch, dass du, wenn du Shift drückst, die Bilder im richtigen Maßstab kleiner machen kannst, ne? Weil das ist dir nicht gelungen. Ich frage jetzt nicht nur, also nicht, weil es schlecht ist, aber du hast kein Geld für Photoshop und alle, und die einzige, Photoshop ist das einzige Programm im Internet, wo man im Maßstabsgetreu Dinge kleiner machen kann. I don't think so. I call bullshit. Schau mal, was von Kim gehört. Aber dann lass uns einfach beide eine Wertung abgeben und die höchste und die niedrigste fliegt raus. Okay, auf welcher Skala? Okay, 1 bis 10 ist es immer 1 bis 10. Ich glaube, beim Skispringen ist es nicht 1 bis 10. Es ist immer 1 bis 10. Wenn man sich auf nichts anderes einigt, ist es immer 1 von zehn. Die Eins von zehn Wertung ist eine Zehn von zehn. Und ich würde hier... Also tut mir leid, wie gesagt, die Bildkomposition ist falsch, der Rahmen ist zu gross, ich bin einfach zu breit auf allen Bildern. Zwei. Zwei von zehn. Stefan, was sagst du? Vier von zehn. Okay, damit die höchste Wertung ist vier fällt raus, die niedrigste ist zwei fällt auch raus, damit keine Wertung, aber vielen Dank für dieses tolle Bild. Fantastisch. Soll ich hier unterschreiben? Ja, natürlich, gerne. Ganz toll gemacht. Bitte schön, danke schön, gerne. Grossen Applaus für diese junge Dame hier. Wow, für zwei von zehn gibt's so einen Applaus, nicht schlecht. Und weil wir heute in so einer charityartigen Oprah Winfrey begeben allen Preise Show sind, kriegst du von Florentin eine Photoshop-Lizenz! Yay, natürlich! Yes, von seinem privaten Geld, nicht von unserem gemeinsamen Konto. Ich hab alles hier in meinem Grossgeschenkgesack. Ich hab After Effects, ich hab Illustrator, ich habe Photoshop, jeder geht heute glücklich nach Hause. Außer einer, der so Media Encoder bekommt. Das war auch immer in der Creative Cloud. Einer hat toll gelacht, der eine, der auch Fotos macht oder so. Habt ihr noch einen Flash Player? Nein, nein. Okay, rated gerne die Unterschrift. Ich bin nicht stolz auf meine Unterschrift. Ich bin auch nicht stolz auf seine Unterschrift, ehrlich gesagt. Ich war einfach zu sehr unter Druck, ich musste, als ich 16 Jahre alt war, meine Unterschrift festlegen. Und wie viele gute Entscheidungen hat man mit 16 getroffen, die man für den Rest seines Lebens nicht bereut? Wenige. Meine Frisur, ehrlich gesagt, habe ich seit 16 nicht mehr angefasst, was jetzt nicht für die Frisur spricht oder für mich als 16-Jährigen. Nein, das hätte aber wesentlich schlimmer laufen können, glaube ich. Also Hattest du schon mal so eine Langhaarphase? Nee, stimmt, ich hatte einmal die Lockenphase. Und Langhaarphase hatte ich nie, nee. Okay. Die Mittelscheilphase. Ich hatte mal die lange Lockenhaarphase. Also das ist, glaube ich, so worst of both worlds. Okay, dann haut mal die Wertung raus für die Unterschrift. Ich gebe euch einen Tipp, es fängt mit F an. Fickt euch. Das F ist der erste Buchstabe. Das ist ein kleines Schreibschrift-F. Das hat eine wunderbare Eigenschaft, so wie in der Schreibschrift oft, dass man nicht erkennt, welcher Buchstabe es sein soll. Was schlecht ist für eine Schrift, aber es ist ein kleines F geworden. Jetzt zeigt das doch nicht rum, ich dachte, das ist hier zwischen uns beiden. Ja doch, wir lassen uns mal einmal umgeben. Das geht doch die letzte Reihe nix an, Augen nach vorne hier. Wir machen das jetzt so, du kannst in diese Richtung weitergeben, dann musst du dich dann einmal... Hört auf jetzt damit, hört auf damit jetzt, hört auf, hört auf. Das war der beste Trick aller Zeiten. Wow, und es hat sogar funktioniert, alles an diesem Moment hat funktioniert. Ja, ich kann auch anders, okay,
ich kann auch ganz anders. Wir haben die Kontrolle, wir kontrollieren die Feuerlöscher hier oben, die treffen euch, nicht uns, wir brennen im Notfall. Jetzt gibt eine Wertung doch ab, ich will, das ist das schlimmste, zwei von zehn, zwei von zehn, ist okay, nicht die schlechteste, nicht die schlechteste, es gibt genug Menschen auf der Welt, die Unterschriften haben, da gibt es bestimmt Leute, die schlechtere haben als ich. Ich habe auch keine gute Unterschrift. Ab welchem Punkt sagt man, ich ändere jetzt meine Unterschrift, also ab welchem Punkt sagt man, jetzt ist der Tag, ich wache auf, acht Uhr morgens, jetzt ist der Tag, neunter, neunter, 2019, jetzt ändere ich meine Unterschrift von Krr zu Lenny Powers oder einfach so, einfach mal so ein Ansagen. Ja, aber auch so Ärzte ist ja das Klischee, dass die immer so krasse Unterschriften haben. Im Prinzip, ich glaube, es kommt aus der, man muss halt irgendwann an irgendeinem Punkt in seinem Leben vielleicht mehr häufiger unterschreiben, als man es vorher gemacht hat. Und deswegen ändert man seine Unterschrift wahrscheinlich, weil es ja einfacher als Arzt ist, wenn ich die ganze Zeit diese, du kriegst Aspirin, du kriegst Aspirpirin, Alakas Aspirin und muss halt neunzigmal diesen Zettel beschreiben, dann mache ich doch nicht irgendwann immer noch Stefan Michael Thieze der Dritte, sondern dann mache ich ja irgendwann einfach nur einen Strich, wie ich bei dem DHL-Boden ja auch nicht meine Unterschrift mache. Niemand von uns macht seine, will ich ihr oder ihre Unterschrift beim RTL-Boden. Wenn du da auf diesem Game Boy Advance da unterschreiben musst, mit diesem Stift, diesem kleinen Krackel einfach. Ja, dann mache ich doch auch einfach einen Strich. Ich habe immer Angst, dass er dann fragt, so kann ich meinen Ausweis sehen? Und dann sage ich so, ne. Ja, ein bisschen so dieses, wie wenig Mühe kann ich mir geben, bis ich Ärger kriege. So diese uralte menschliche Frage, so ab wann sagt jemand, Entschuldigung, wir sind hier von der Unterschriftenbehörde, so geht es aber mal gar nicht, das ist keine Unterschrift, das ist ein Strich.
Ja genau, also es wäre ja schon bei DHL immer spannend, ob ich einfach so einen X machen kann oder so einen gemalten Mittelfinger.
Oder so den Boten malen oder so, einfach so eine Karikatur.
Ja, so eine Karikatur.
Einfach random, offen, die kleine Kirsche.
Auch hier die Frage, wie lange würde es dauern, bis der sagt, so, danke.
Ja genau, wenn man sich wirklich diesen Stick so anfeucht so. So, Kunst braucht Zeit. Der schreibt nicht. Kunst braucht Zeit. Und so ein Tintenfass einfach rein. Ja, war auch schön. Hattest du mal einen Tintenfass? Ich hatte mal einen Tintenfass, ja, tatsächlich. Meine Mutter, also wir alle haben Eltern und wir alle haben so ein bisschen so eine Grundausstattung, Grundausstattung, so wie man so in einem Rollenspiel eine Klasse wählt, hängt es glaube ich so von den Eltern ab, welche Klasse du startest. Moment, du musst mich mitnehmen als Non-Gamer. Naja, ob du jetzt halt so, wenn du ein Zauberer bist, hast du einen Zauberstab am Anfang, wenn du Schurke bist, hast du einen Dolch am Anfang. Und so ist es im Leben auch, wenn du halt Sohn von einem Musiker bist, dann startest du direkt mit einer Geige. Dirigierstab. Das ist so deine Standardausrüstung. Und je nachdem, wie cool deine Eltern sind, desto cool ist deine Standardausrüstung. Meine Mutter hatte einen Schreibbahnladen. Das heisst, ich hatte in meinem Start-Equipment Naturschutzpapier, das braune und einen schönen Filfederhalter. Pergament und Feder, eigentlich wie Harry Potter. Ja, genau. Was sich wieder cool macht. Ich dachte mir, ich mache das Beste draus, ich bin jetzt einfach der Typ, der die Füllfederhalter hat und die Tinte, aber es hat nicht funktioniert. Es hat nicht funktioniert, Löschpapier kam dazwischen, hat mich gebrochen. Löschpapier hat mich gebrochen. Immer schön die schlechten Noten bekommen, weil Löschpapier gefehlt hat. Aber es ist schwierig, an welchem Tag ändert man sein Leben. Ich kann mich noch erinnern, dass ich als Kind versucht habe, irgendwie ein USP zu generieren. Erst wollte ich immer der sein, der einen Lutscher im Geldbeutel dabei hat. Weil Rauchen fand ich cool, aber konnte ich nicht. Deswegen hatte ich einen Lutscher und dachte, es ist ähnlich, die Leute merken es nicht. Warum diese Geldbeutel-Zwischensache? Ja, damit ich ihn parat habe, damit ich ihn mal den rausziehen kann. Und dann dachte ich mir, weil das war zu viel Aufwand, den immer mit mir rumzutragen, und ich habe den dann oft gelutscht, während niemand hingeguckt hat, und das verschwendet dann, weil niemand weiss, dass es ist. Es ist rausgeschmissenes Geld für Lutscher. Es ist rausgeschmissenes Imagegeld. Weil es kein Genussmittel ist, sondern rein für Image. Mein ganzes Imagebudget für diese Woche ist einfach nur auf acht Chubber-Chubs draufgegangen, die ich dann allein im Wald gelutscht habe, erbärmlich. Okay. Da dachte ich mir, es wird auch viel kostengünstiger, auf eine coole Art zu reden, und deswegen dachte ich mir, ich sage immer alles zweimal. Also ich sage, wenn man sich trifft und der eine sagt Hi, dann sage ich Hi, Hi. Es fällt noch nicht auf, es fällt noch nicht auf. Hey, Florentin, es geht, hast du schon Bio gemacht? Nee, nee. Okay, bislang merke ich nichts an meinem Mitschüler, was weird ist. Kann ich vielleicht bei dir abschreiben? Klar, nein, nein, weil ich das nicht habe, weil ich die Hausaufgabe nicht habe. Lange Sätze sage ich nicht zweimal.
Nur so ein Wort antworten, so snappy, so kurze Sachen sage ich.
Lass uns noch mal reinkommen.
Das ist zu... Lass uns einen ganz langen Weg machen.
Und wir sehen uns schon ganz früh.
Aber was ist das Setting?
Muss ich mir Mitschüler vorstellen im Gang? Mitschüler, Gang, links und rechts. Lass uns auf drei umdrehen, okay? Eins, zwei, drei. Sorry, sorry, sorry, hey, hey, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, Entschuldigung. Sorry. Hey alter, hast du Bio schon geschrieben, Biosaufgaben? Nee, nee, das ist das Schwachste, ich komme nochmal rein, es hat aber wirklich nicht lange durchgehalten, es hat nicht lange durchgehalten. Aber hey, cooler Lutscher. Haha, danke, danke.
Manchmal geht's, manchmal geht's. Es hat nicht lange nicht gehalten. Aber hey, cooler Lutscher.
Danke, danke.
Manchmal geht's, manchmal geht's, manchmal nicht.
Vor allem, ich denke mir dann immer, man hat dann sich so Druck gemacht und so, aber die Mitschüler sind ja auch nach Hause gegangen und dachten, lagen dann abends so im Bett und dachten, fuck ey, der ist so cool und sagt alles zweimal. Ja.
Und ich sag immer nur alles einmal.
Und ich hab nicht mal so einen geilen Lutscher.
Wenn ich ab morgen alles dreimal sag vielleicht, bin ich dann noch cooler als er. Okay, and here we go. Aber jetzt mal diesmal ohne Hindernisse, okay, dass wir uns die ganze Zeit sehen, aber nicht genau wissen, ab wann wir anfangen sollen zu... Okay, wir sagen lächerlich wenig Hindernisse, okay? Okay, viel zu freier Gang, unnatürlich für den normalen Schultag. Weird, weird für die erste Stunde, mega seltsam, okay. Okay. Viel zu freier Gang, unnatürlich für den normalen Schultag.
Weird, weird für die erste Stunde, mega seltsam. Okay, drei, zwei, eins. Hey, hey, hey! Hey Mann, ist so leer heute, findest du nicht? Ja, ja, ja. Hast du Bio, hast du Bio, hast du Bio? Ich wollte dich grad fragen, ich wollte dich grad fragen, ich wollte dich gerade fragen, ich wollte dich gerade fragen, denn ich mache jetzt Poetry Slam und das ist so mein neues Ding, Ding, was ist mein Ding, Seed hat ein Ding. Ich wechsel die Schule, ich wechsel die Schule, ich habe hier keine Chance mehr zu überleben. Aber ja, es hat nie funktioniert, ich bin nie cool geworden.
Doch, du bist cool!
Nein, aber ich wüsste, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, Leute, billigster Applaus abholen.
Doch du bist cool, wir alle finden dich cool.
Nein, nein, nein, ich meine, ich will so, ich will, dass man so von mir so eine Actionfigur kauft und weiss, ah, wenn man das Teil irgendwann verliert, weiss man, ah, das gehört zu Florian Rien.
So, wenn du, du hast ja so Actionfiguren, die haben was in der Hand und das verlieren die dann und dann finden sie es und sagen, ah ja klar, das gehört bei Admin. Du kannst es halt so besser vermarkten, wenn du so ein Item hast, so irgendwie so. Das habe ich halt nicht. Immer so ein Regenschirm dabei oder so oder immer so eine Spitzhacke oder irgendwas, keine Ahnung. Jogginghose wird reingerufen. Nochmal bitte? Irgendwie wurde jetzt auch so eine Reinrufkultur entwickelt, aber Jogginghose wurde gerufen, finde ich auch gut, dass man einfach so eine Jogginghose vorne und hinten so dran kleppen kann. Ja, das stimmt. Die waren ja auch nie aus Stoff, sondern immer so Plastik, kann man so von vorne und hinten dran kleben und ist so eine Wechseljogginghose. Ja. Aber auch unrealistisch, aber dass man so drei Jogginghosen hat, die man dir anziehen kann. Drei gleich aussehende J-Hosen, die man dir anziehen kann. Wer entscheidet eigentlich, ob bei Actionfiguren unter der Kleidung noch eine Unterhose ist oder gar nichts? Ist das ein Meeting? Ja, und wie es vor allem aussieht, ne, untenrum. Ja, ist das ein Meeting, wo man sagt so, nee, lass uns eine Unterhose machen, also lass uns das nochmal schwarz färben und einer sagt, nee, lass uns einfach, aber warum nicht? Naja, also, nee. Nee, Hautfarbe. Wieso, aber lass uns doch einfach nochmal, nee, so richtig, so rote Hautfarbe. Nee, aber lass uns doch einfach nochmal, ist ja eh glatt, da ist ja eh nichts, aber lass uns einfach nur für die Kinder nochmal. Ach so, wie, da ist nichts. Nee, da ist nichts, einfach glatt, das sind Kindersachen, das sind die Turtles, was sollen die haben, das sind Schildkröten. Na ja. Marc, du siehst unglücklich aus. Sag mal, was dein Problem ist.
Ich will, dass alle mit unserer neuen Turtles-Linie richtig zufrieden sind. Und du siehst noch nicht glücklich aus. Das ist doch auch unrealistisch, weil Schildkröten, die haben ja auch, ich weiß, ich habe Turtles nie gesehen, sorry, sorry, sorry, wir reden gleich drüber.
Aber die haben doch bestimmt auch mal irgendwann Freundinnen, oder nicht?
Weiss ich nicht. Es gibt diese eine gelbe Frau.
Ja? Das ist doch die Freundin von Rafael, Leonardo, da Vinci oder Lothar.
Es gibt diese Carla-Columna-Figur, aber die machen, glaube ich, was sollen die deine Meinung ineinander haben jetzt?
Hey, wenn die eine Liebesbeziehung haben und so, und das Publikum wird ja auch älter mit den Figuren. Steh mal auf, wenn du redest, bitte. Mal doch mal an die Tafel, was du denkst, dass die da unter dem Panzer haben sollen. Wir haben Tafel, wir haben kein cooles Whiteboard, das ist kein cooles Startup. Nein, wir haben Tafeln, da ist die Packung Kreide. Ja. Was soll das denn sein? So ein Haken? Kein Haken, oder? Wir haben es zu sagen. Ich mal's ... Mal's noch mal. Warte, wisch noch mal weg bitte. Ich wisch noch mal weg. Nee, und danach musst du auch ... So. Ja, aber ist die noch zu nass? Jetzt die Tafel. Okay, entschuldige. Dann nehme ich den Lappen. Ja, es ist wichtig, dass du den Lappen dann nochmal benutzt. Warum machen wir das eigentlich in einem Klassenraum? Weil wir Spielzeug für Kinder machen, Mark, okay? Ja, aber warum machen wir das in einer leeren Schule, ist so weird, Jesus. Damit wir in den Gängen nicht aufgehalten werden, Mark. Wir müssen uns schnell bewegen können. Jetzt habe ich nicht hingeschaut. Okay, wir machen das genau so. Wir machen das genau so. Wenn die Kinder die Hosen von den Turtles ausziehen, sollen sie das sehen. Für immer verstört sein. Aber habe ich schon häufig gehört, dass Leute so, also relativ berühmte Filmkritiker, das auch an Harry Potter und so ein bisschen kritisiert haben, dass die zwar älter werden, die Figuren und das Publikum ja auch mit denen älter wird und es jetzt schon auch den Anspruch hat, so ein bisschen so eine Coming-of-Light-Stire zu sein, aber dann haben die nie was miteinander. Okay, ja, kann ich verstehen, aber ich frage mich, wer Harry Potter einsieht, anschaut und sagt, warum haben die keinen Sex eigentlich? Ja, aber genau das war ja die Kritik. Er sagt auch Sex. Warum haben die keinen Sex? Papa, Papa, bist du es? Ich habe so gehofft, dass ich nicht mit dir den... Ich hatte in die Waldartig Sex. Papa, die sind... Adisch Sex. Adisch Sex. Aber die Frage ist, was ist denn genau der Moment?
Ich sage auch nicht, dass es meine Meinung ist, ich sage nur, es ist schon einfach so ein bisschen...
Ja, aber du hast auch eine Verantwortung für Meinungen, die du in den Raum trägst, okay?
Du kannst dir einfach sagen, es gibt die Meinung, dass...
Dann müssen wir 307 Folgen überdenken, aber...
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber ja, schon ein bisschen weird, schon eher soft.
Also du hast dann diesen Lorbeer-Strauch, nein, ist es auch nicht, wie heißt das nochmal, Nistelzweig, und hast dann Joe und Harry, die ein bisschen, nicht mal mit Zunge... Zunge hätte dir schon gereicht, da hättest du gesagt, ich bin jetzt für zwei Jahre zufrieden, und dann schauen wir nochmal, welche Rolle Dobby spielt, so, da guckt man mal, ich meine, er ist frei, er ist fucking frei, er kann machen was er will.
Ich will Dobby den Lennenschutz, als ob der in seiner Sklavenzeit viel Action gesehen hat, natürlich muss der danach was nachholen, ist doch klar. Dobby mal so den Lappen wegziehen. Jesus, Jesus Christ, how did we end up here? In deleted scenes!
Naja, es ist ja auch kein Schauspiel, es ist einfach so eine kleine Figur, wahrscheinlich so eine Wachsfigur, die da am Set steht und so. Er hat doch bestimmt mal jemand den Gag gemacht. Bestimmt. Aber ich weiss auch nicht, ob wir das noch länger vertiefen sollen. Ich glaube, wir haben alle sehr konkrete Bilder im Kopf, die wir ähnlich wie die Turtle-Genitalien nicht aus dem Kopf kriegen. So unähmlich. Aber auch zum Beispiel Herr der Ringe, ich habe mir mal so ein Wörterbuch angeguckt von der Herr der Ringe-Sprache, Elbisch und so, Sindarin, ja. War das vorn und nach der Lutscher-Sache? Das war ziemlich währenddessen. Hm, da habe ich mir schon gedacht. Das haben uns alle gedacht. Ja, alle haben so mit Anglizismen angefangen und ich dachte, vielleicht kriege ich so Sindarinozismen rein oder so, dass ich so Gallert sage, Schattlicht oder so. Einz Wort, das ich kenne. Galat, Galat, und die … Das ist leider auch ein Wort, das es auf Deutsch gibt. Galat, ja wie Galadriel halt, die heisst nicht Galadriel. Hör mal auf jetzt hier, das ist gerade wichtig. Nee, ich spreche halt diesen Akzent, diesen südlichen Akzent. Wir Südländer von Mittelerde sprechen das Galat auch. Okay, alles klar. Und die haben kein Wort für irgendwas Versautes, nichts, gar nichts, null. Ich habe alles geprüft, jedes... Ja, warum sollte man das so genau wissen, eigentlich? Ich habe mir eine Liste gemacht von allen versauten Wörtern, die ich kenne, da waren teilweise Werte dabei, die gar nicht so versaut sind, trotzdem nicht drin, trotzdem nicht drin. Keine Chance, in Elbisch irgendwie mal was anzutrennt. Einen zotigen Witz zu machen, für den du ja bekannt bist. Ist absolut unmöglich. Ich hätte, glaube ich, bei so einem elbischen Stand-Up-Abend einen richtig harten Tag, weil ihr kennt mich für meine zotigen Sex-Games. Nö, du würdest einfach so PG-12-Programm machen, so sehr clean Comedy einfach, toll. Ja, das ist, glaube ich, Lembers, oder? Oder? Lembers kennt jemand?
Das Brot.
Das Brot?
Ihr seid jetzt auch Elben-Publikum, Leute, das muss jetzt, Jesus Christ.
Oder, Lembers Brot?
Ähm.
Puh, ich bin Gollum und mag's nicht.
Okay.
Ganz schön trocken, oder?
So trocken wie der Humor von Elrond, nicht wahr? Dankeschön. Dankeschön, macht's gut, ich bin auf Wasser heute Abend, schau. Wir sehen uns in 10.000 Jahren wieder, macht's gut. Stimmt, wie lange ist so ein Elben-Stand-Up-Abend? Viel zu lang. Ich meine, wenn dein Leben ein Lifecycle ist, also so einer ganzen Welt, und du lebst, ich weiß nicht wie viele, tausend Erden. Du hast jeden Gag schon mal gehört, das ist auch ein Problem, natürlich, du kannst nicht touren. Aber ich finde es schade, dass bei Herr der Ringe selten auf Hobbys eingegangen wurde von den Leuten. Es gab so viele Szenen, so irgendwie dann in Rohan, sitzt man mal rum oder so, kann da nicht Legolas sagen, so, ich schreibe gerade so ein paar Comedy-Sachen gerade, habt ihr, also wenn der Krieg jetzt vorbei ist und Sauron. Und Aragon schon so, oh Gott, wir wollten doch jetzt die Reise planen jetzt nach Mordor. Ja, ja, ja, nee, klar, aber überlegt ihr euch nicht manchmal irgendwie, was wir nach Mordor machen und so, nach Sauron, weil ich dachte so ein kleiner Club, zwei Drink Minimum oder so, irgendwie schön. Das gefällt mir, so Band of Brothers Gespräche, so während des zweiten Weltkriegs, wo Leute so, was machen wir danach, wenn wir wieder nach Hause kommen.
Ja, was machen wir danach irgendwie, könnt ihr mal vorbeikommen, ihr kriegt einen Drink umsonst oder so.
Du hast doch das mit diesem Hochbeten für dich entdeckt.
Ja, weiss ich nicht, die sind zu hoch, das weiss ich nicht.
Kannst du runtersetzen?
Und da kann ich auch drauf laufen, glaube ich, oder?
Ja.
Ich glaube, das wäre mein erster Tag als Lego, dass ich würde gucken, worauf ich laufen kann, weil er kann ja auf Schnee laufen. Ach so, das muss ich sagen. Ja, aber jeder kann auf Schnee laufen. Nee, die anderen sinken ein. Hast du den Film überhaupt gesehen? Moment, grosser was? Legolas kann oben auf dem Schnee laufen, während alle anderen einsinken. Kann der jetzt auch einfach über hohes Gras laufen, oder kann der einfach über so ein Rosenbeet laufen? Oder was ist mit Nebel? Kann er über das Wasser laufen? Was ist mit Nebel? Also wo ist da die Grenze? Konnte Jesus über Schnee laufen? Jesus konnte ja auch nicht, also Jesus konnte das Wasser, nein, Moses, nein, Moses konnte das Wasser, Moses konnte Schnee spalten. Er wurde überall gerufen, so, Moses, komm mal vorbei, hier meine ganze Einfahrt, es ist so mit Schnee. Moses, komm mal vorbei, Moses, noch einmal. Und man spalt, ich schau nicht alles weg, da die ganze Strasse. Aber gute Frage. Wir haben zum ersten Mal den Akzent, den Lokaldialekt einigermaßen hinbekommen. Endlich, ja. Viel Spaß in der Wien-Show, das wird sehr aufregend. Aber es ist eigentlich eine gute Frage, kann Jesus auf Schnee laufen und kann er Schnee in so einen Weinslaschi verwandeln? Ja! Wenn ihr wirklich mal so das Eisabenteuer von Jesus oder so bei den Polarbären und dann einfach so, oh, ich bin durstig, klar, kein Problem. So ein Schneeball, typischer Jesus-Satz, klar, klar, klar, klar, ich weiß, wann ich gebraucht werde, okay? Und dann so ein Schneeball und dann mach mal Mut auf.
Sag mal, weil wir frieren alle, dankeschön.
Wir frieren alle … ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, probier mal, probier mal, probier mal, probier den Schneeball mal, ohne Scheiss, probier mal.
Das ist nicht wieder so ein Dornending wie … Ja, ist …
Das ist ganz geil, das ist ein Weinslasch, ist ein Spätburgunder, extra für dich aufgehoben.
Weil er so spät gekommen ist.
Ja.
Weil, ne, weil für dich aufgehoben.
Weil er so spät gekommen ist.
Weil, nee, weil wir frieren alle mega. Kannst du uns nicht irgendwie ein Glühwein machen?
Schwer. Auch gut, als du so ein Vatersohn.
Schwer, Glühwein.
Nee, weil das wäre echt mega, weil wir frieren alle mega, weißt du?
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, nee, kann ich nix, ich kann, glaube ich, ich kann Tische umschmeissen, ich kann die Reichen vertreiben, aber leider nicht wärmen, sorry, da musste dir Johannes den Täufer holen, sorry, da bin ich nicht der Richtige.
Für Glühwein, den Täufer?
Ja, der kann wärmen und so, der kann wärmen, äh, so, kontraintuitiv, sorry, sorry. Sorry, der war zu hoch. Habe ich dem Petrus auf den Kopf gehauen. Aber ist schwierig. Gibt es da noch so Nebenabenteuer von Jesus? War der noch mal
irgendwie in der Antarktis oder so, in so einer Lava-Welt? Ja, oder diese Hochbeetsache. Ich
check's nicht ganz so. Ich auch nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Ich hab's einmal irgendwo gelesen. Versuchst
du subtil deine Hochbeetphase einzuleiten, weil man jetzt sagt, Stefan macht jetzt Hochbeete. Nee, ich weiß noch gar nicht, warum hoch, wenn man für den Rücken angenehmer ist. Ist das Beet hoch oder sind die Pflanzen hoch? Also Beet ist hoch, habe ich gerade... Alles hoch? Alles ist riesengroß. Alles ist hoch, aber das ist auch unsere Welt, immer alles ein bisschen höher, ein bisschen grösser. Die Gegenidee von Minigolf, zu sagen Hochgolf, fuck it, alles richtig hoch, Hochbeet. Um den Rücken zu schonen wahrscheinlich, um im Stehen die Beete zu pflegen. Toll. Weiß nicht, wo uns das hinführt, jedenfalls bei Jesus, hat glaube ich nichts gemacht in der Hinsicht. Aber ich glaube, irgendein Kumpel von mir wollte sich das mal wünschen. Und seitdem hat es sich in meinen Kopf gesetzt. Oh, ich verstehe, du hast einen Wunsch irgendwo abgespeichert, weisst aber nicht mehr wer. Das kenne ich auch. Das ist es. Irgendwer hat das mit Hochbeten angefangen. Ja, genau. Wenn Marianne Geburtstag hat und er sagt, irgendjemand hat sich dieses Diabolo, zwei Stöcke Hochschmeissding gewünscht, wenn sie es nicht war, dann wird es ein sehr unangenehmer Geburtstag. Das wird so unangenehm. Ich kann Marianne nicht einfach so dieses Diavolo Diabolo. Oma, nochmal kurz, Oma Marianne hat sich ein Diabolo gewünscht? Ja, weil die sich nicht... Was will sie damit machen? Nein, der ist es unangenehm, nochmal in den Sportladen zu gehen und sich die Kindersachen zu kaufen. Deswegen will sie es geschenkt haben. Oma Marianne sitzt im Rollstuhl. Was will die denn mit einem Diabolo? Ja, die will es noch mal richtig krachen lassen jetzt. Die sagt, noch habe ich Arme, let's fucking go. Das waren ihre Worte. Meine Arme funktionieren noch, here we go Diabolo. Ich hole da jetzt alles raus, das waren ihre Worte. Ja, da gibt jemand, der Diabolo-Fan war, jetzt haben wir die Sportart ruiniert. Oder ist ein Geschenk gerade eingefallen, scheisse Marianne, ich habe mich zum Geburtstag gratuliert. Ich wusste, der Termin kollidiert. Welches Geschenk kriegt man jetzt noch? Welche Optionen hat sie gerade noch? Tanke, schön Cheo-Chips, noch mal eine Packung? Cheo-Chips geht immer. Was natürlich die beste Idee eigentlich ist, die ich immer aufgeschnappt habe, von einer Freundin ist Lotto-Scheine oder so Rubbellose. So Ruppell ist eigentlich, man kann was gewinnen und so und man hat was zu tun, aber so Last-Mill-Geschenkt-Rubbellose finde ich nicht so schlecht. Sorry, aber das ist... Aber ich wäre so sauer, wenn... Ja eben, ich wollte es gerade sagen! Weil die Person, die man schenkt, ist ja unwichtig, das hätte man gerne eine fucking Rubbellose gekauft. Sonst hätte man eine bessere Idee. Das hätte man eine bessere Idee, ja. Sorry an alle, die von ihren Liebsten Rubbellose geschenkt bekommen haben. Hard to break it to you, ja da unten zeigt jemand auf. Oh wirklich? Du ihr oder sie du? Nein, das ist ein Scherz. Oh wirklich? Oh, aber hast du was gewonnen? Drei Euro! Wow! Und wie teuer waren die Rubbellose, musst du nicht sagen, sag's. Fünfzehn Euro. Okay. Zwei Jahre. Zwei Jahre. Hat sie an deiner ersten Reaktion nicht gemerkt, dass es ein scheites Geschenk ist? Nein, es ist ein tolles Gefühl. Aber ernsthaft, du hättest dich ein bisschen geärgert, wenn ihr jetzt zwei Millionen gewonnen hättet, oder? Nein, ihr seid verheiratet. Ah, ihr seid verheiratet, okay, alles freut mich für euch. Ist doch schön. Schauen wir mal, wie es in der nächsten Tour aussieht. Das haben wir schon häufiger gehört, und dann wird es drei Jahre verschoben.
Dann wird es drei Jahre verschoben und dann sind sie geschieden, aber wieder verheiratet auch. Ja, meine Ex. Aber du kannst jetzt halt mal einmal sagen, was du dir eigentlich wünschst. Hochbeet. Wunschlos glücklich, okay. Sollen wir sie kurz rausschicken? Hochbeet. Hochbeet, okay, alles klar, okay. Brauch noch ein Hochbeet. Machst du das vielleicht? Tatsächlich, wir lesen alle eure Kommentare und wir schreiben alle eure Wünsche auf und wir wissen, wann ihr Geburtstag habt und wir wissen genau, wer sich was wünscht und ihr kriegt ein schönes Geschenk von uns. Die meisten von euch wünschen sich Merch, soweit wir das wissen, oder? Nein? Sie hatte gestern Geburtstag, alles Gute zum Geburtstag. Bitte nicht singen, bitte nicht singen, bitte nicht singen. Sehr schön. Denkst du, du gehst gerade, bitte, lass dich nicht den ganzen Raum singen. Bitte lass auf gar keinen Fall alle singen. Nein. Und ich verstehe dich. Wir singen nicht Happy Birthday, sondern wir singen was anderes. Wir singen, hast du eine Idee? I wanna stand with you on a mountain.
Aber der Song heißt anders, ne?
Weiß ich.
I'll stand by you.
Okay, Achtung, los geht's, Achtung, wir singen alle für die junge Dame die Geburtstag.
Aber jeder singt, das finde ich ganz lustig, jeder singt den ersten Song, der ihm einfällt.
Oh, okay.
Okay, aber nicht jetzt irgendwie einfach das reines Assoziationsspiel, alle singen gleichzeitig. Und singt auch den Song, wenn ihr den Text nicht kennt, okay? Los geht's, drei, zwei, I wanna stand with you on a mountain, I wanna lay with you in the sea, you can make me whole again. Weil ich glaube, das wäre jetzt das schönste Geschenk und du so, ja klar, schenke ich zwei Millionen geärgert. Hat irgendjemand ein Rubbellos? Hier, ich schaue in die erste Reihe, keins mehr übrig. Macht man das nicht so, dass man sagt, eins jetzt, eins morgen oder so? Ne? Ja, wenn man ein sehr langweiliges Leben hat, dann machen wir das. Keiner ein Rubbellos. Wir besorgen nur noch ein Rubbellos, okay, wir schicken dir ein Rubbellos zu. Wir besorgen dir ein Rubbellos und schicken es dir, das muss schon sein. Das muss schon sein. Finde ich auch nicht so schlecht. Und die Hälfte geht an uns, hast du gewinnst, okay?
Das ist schon was Schade sein.
Aber wo du gerade beim Thema...
1,50, ja.
1,50.
Die Hälfte von drei Jahren, stimmt, ja.
Wo wir gerade beim Thema Diabolos waren.
Ich war am Sonntag im Zirkus in Köln.
Wow, Stefan!
Im Zirkus!
Ja, und ich meine, das war das erste Mal seit wahrscheinlich so 20 Jahren, 21, 22 Jahren, und es war, es hat sich auch so angefühlt wie etwas, was man vor 22 Jahren gemacht hat. Du hast die Storyline nicht mehr bekommen. Warum ist der ganz oben? Warum ist der Elefant jetzt auf dem Trapez? Es gibt keine Tiere mehr. Es gibt gar keine Tiere mehr? Es gibt keine Tiere mehr. Null. Null Tiere, null. Der Zirkus-Ronkalle hat sich ausschliesslich auf Artistik konzentriert. Glaube, ich habe nicht so viel gesehen, mein Platz war direkt hinter so einer Säule. Also, und wir sind heute Mittag schon mal ein bisschen hier rumgelaufen, es gibt Leute mit ähnlichen Problemen. Ja, kleiner Shout-on an alle, die jetzt einen Podcast hören. Das Säulenpublikum, die bezahlt haben, um einen Podcast zu hören. Gäste Liste Geisterbahn meinen wir, schön nebenbei reinhören. Aber es ist ja auch die Idee, also ich meine, das Problem ist ja hausgemacht, weil die sich ja belegt haben, in einem Zelt ihr Kram zu machen. Und das Zelt hat halt nur mal Zeltstangen und eine grosse, runde Manege, weshalb aussenrum diese ganze Zeltstangen stehen, die inzwischen sehr gross sind, weil die Zelte so gross sind, und man saß einfach hinter dieser Säule. Aber was, also was war die enttäuschendste Nummer? Wo hast du gesagt, dafür hätte ich auch zu Hause bleiben können? Hast du dir irgendwas anguckt? Ja, es war ein Jongleur da, der mit drei Bällen viel jongliert hat, wo ich dachte, ja, ich habe auch schon mal mit drei Bällen jongliert, ich habe schon mal mit drei Orangen jongliert, so easy. Und der hat auch mit so drei Blöcken jongliert und so, und es kam auch nicht mehr so gut an. Da dachte ich so, ja, vor 20 Jahren hätte man da wahrscheinlich noch applaudiert. Inzwischen kennt man Leute, die mit 16 Blöcken bei TikTok jeden Tag dreimal machen und dabei zu Katie Melua ein Hochbeet bepflanzen. So, das hat man dann schon gesehen und deswegen waren die Ansprüche und er hat auch nicht so viel Applaus bekommen. Und er hat sich dann aber so mega professionell und alt mit diesem geilen Zirkus-Outfit und so verabschiedet und so. Ich dachte, er sitzt gleich in der Maske und denkt so, während er das Abschminken so. Das hat nicht so gut funktioniert heute. Oh nein. Die alte Nummer funktioniert nicht mehr. Die Leute wollen mehr, als meine drei Bälle haben, die Luft wirbeln, als mein Ballwirbelwind, den ich jedes Jahr performe. Aber das Geile an meinem billigen Platz war, war, dass man von hinten gucken konnte in die Magienummer. Was natürlich ganz geil ist, weil das da, also das ist für alle Dinge, die da passiert sind, der schlechteste Platz gewesen, auch weil ich von hinten einfach die ganze Zeit auf die Leute geguckt habe, ausser für diese Magienummer halt, weil man halt von hinten immer die Tricks reingucken konnte. Und es war halt so ein, die Magienummer war so sehr schnell Outfits wechseln, so eine Verkleidungskünstlerin. Oh ja, immer gern gesehen. Und dann haben die ja dann oft so, keine Ahnung, so grosse Fächer oder sowas und machen das dann so vor dich. Ich mach's kurz nach. Okay, in die Richtung geht das, okay, ich verstehe. Das sind so grosse Fächer und dann machen die den und dann machen die weg und dann hast du ein anderes Outfit an. Ja, also ich jetzt nicht, aber ja, okay. Und dann machen die es nochmal und das wieder ein Outfit an. Und das machen die fünfzehn Mal und man denkt beim 14. Mal so, ich hab's verstanden. Ja. Man denkt auch schon beim dritten Mal, ich hab's verstanden, aber und ich konnte halt von hinten reingucken und dachte mir, mindblowing, ich sehe, wie sie es macht. Aber du darfst es nicht verraten, du darfst es nicht verraten, der maskierte Magier kommt zu uns und bringt uns alle um, du darfst auf gar keinen Fall verraten, wie es geht. Das ist gegen den Magierkodex. Ich bin nicht in der Gilde. Ich bin nicht in der Gilde. Nein, nein, nein, du kannst einerseits nicht mehr Harry Potter Sex verlangen und andererseits die Geheimnisse verraten. Entweder du liebst Magie oder du tust es nicht. Es gibt nur die zwei Möglichkeiten. Okay, ich tue es nicht. Denn, wie sie es macht. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein nichts. Es ist Magie. Und dann dachte ich mir, ja, vielleicht hat sie einfach echte Magie, vielleicht kann sie zaubern. Ja. Aber weil das niemand glauben würde, machen die dann das mit diesen Fächern und diesen Röhren, weil, ich meine, es ist, selbst von hinten habe ich gedacht, das ist impossible. Wie macht sie das? Es ist Pech, wenn du halt eine Superkraft kriegst, die halt bedeutet, du kannst dich schnell umziehen. Du kannst dich nicht den Avengers anschliessen, die lehnen dich ab. Ich glaube doch. Aber du musst zum Zirkus gehen, du musst einfach sagen, ja, ich mache meinen Trick und so und ja, wunderbar. Man fantasiert ja oft so, was macht man, wenn man so eine Fährbedienung hat, die die Zeit anhält und ich dachte, ich werde Zauberer. Und dann habe ich dann irgendwie keinen Hasen im Hut und dann pausiere ich alles, dann hole ich einen Hasen.
Kann ja lange dauern, ich bin nicht gut im Hasenjagen, das dauert eine Woche, sind wir ganz ehrlich. Und du bist nicht auf die Idee gekommen, vorher den Hasen zu jagen. Ne, da weisst du ja noch nicht, ob ich den Auftritt überhaupt bekomme. Also ich muss ja erst mal gucken, kriege ich den Auftritt, stehe ich da mit dem Hut, dann pausiere ich, dann jage ich wirklich lächerlich lange, lange, ich werde schneller müde als der Hase, dann habe ich den Hasen, pack ihn rein, mach wieder Start, harter Jumpcut, harter Jumpcut, ich wechsle den Ort schlagartig, hol den Hasen raus, Riesen-Nummer. Und dann habe ich mir auch gedacht, ja dafür brauchst du eigentlich keine dummen Fernbedienungen, das geht auch so, aber das war meine erste Idee, wo ich mir dachte, meine Herren, du wärst der schlechteste Superheld der Welt, der seine Superkraft am wenigsten gut verwenden könnte. Remote man. Ja genau, du hast die Superkraft, du kannst deine Gliedmassen lang machen. Und ich so, oh geil, dann kann ich in der Badewanne liegen und mir was zu trinken aus der Küche holen. Und so zehn Jahre später, fuck, ich kann die Welt retten, ich trottel, fuck, wie dumm bin ich. Daran denkst du jetzt als erstes? Ja, oder nicht? Ich würde jetzt daran denken, wie ich in der Badeweine das mit dem Hotdog mache. Ich habe oft das Problem, dass ich in der Badeweine liege und mir noch irgendwas einfällt, was ich brauche. Noch ein Glas Gurken aus dem Kühlschrank oder so. Und dann denke ich mir, was könnte, wenn jetzt mein Arm so ganz lang wäre und dann könnte ich mir das so rausholen und dann fühle ich das und so, aber geht leider nicht. Schade. Ich fand es faszinierend, weil ich dachte wirklich, die kann wahrscheinlich wirklich zaubern, aber es ist der lamest Trick. Ja. Vor allem, ja, und dann dachte ich mir, warum lassen die das nicht einfach weg und sie macht das so, weil das ist ja, aber das ist wahrscheinlich einfach zu krass. Das ist einfach ein Mechanismus, den sie irgendwie hat. Ich verstehe es nicht, aber ich finde es auch auf der anderen Betrachtung. Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, hätte ich diesen Trick, ich hätte gar nicht genug Kleidung, um mich mehr als zweimal umzuziehen. Ich glaube, mir helft ihr das hier, Hose, Toast und dann wieder das hier. So, es ist einfach immer und dann denkst du dich so, wow. Und du so, die ist leicht anders. Die Jonghyhose mixen sich gar nicht. Ja, okay. Dunkelblau, schwarz, dunkelblau, schwarz. Wow. Niemand klatscht und du so, nee, die ist eine andere, man sieht es nicht. Nee, die. Nee, die ist von Nike hier unten, ihr seht das, nee, guck mal, nee, guck mal. Man sieht es hinter den ausschließlich aus Säulen bestehenden Manege nicht, aber die ist leicht dunkelblau. Aber hast du dir irgendwas abgeguckt, also hat sich deine Leidenschaft für Zauberei geweckt? Nee, und dann, was auch auffällt, weil es war total cool zu erkennen, weil es waren sehr viele, sehr, sehr viele Kinder da. Warst du der einzige Erwachsener? Ja. Ja. Und man hat immer, und das Geile ist, dass die alle in der Pause, diese, die man irgendwie mit dem Zirkus ja auch verbindet, diese so Lichterkarussells geschenkt bekommen haben von ihren Eltern, sind so Dinger, die man anmacht und dann drehen die sich im Kreis und blinken ganz doll und sind irgendwie so, machen so Kreise, zeichnen die in die Luft. Und man hat dann ganz gut gesehen in der zweiten Hälfte dieses Zirkusauftritts, wann es den Kindern langweilig wurde, weil man dann so, wenn man sich so in den Rund geguckt hat, im Publikum, hat man immer gesehen, bei dieser Umziehnummer waren die Kinder alle raus und so nach und dann ging es dem Publikum dann diese Blinkdinger an und es war so geil. Und dann kam der Clown und alle Blinkdinger aus und dann haben nur Kinder auch immer gelacht über den Clown, so ganz laut, dieses laute Kinderlachen. Und dann kam wieder so eine lame Artistiknummer und dann wieder... Oh, das ist gemein, ey. Aber das war auch geil. Die direkte Rückmeldung einfach. Gefällt uns, gefällt das nicht. Mir ist das passiert auf so einem Mittelaltermarkt, weil ich mir unterwegs war, dann gab es so ein Märchenzelt und ich dachte mir einfach, safe bin ich dabei, ist genau meine Weltmärchen.
Und dann setze ich mich da hin, erster, und dann setze ich so ein kleines Mädchen neben mich, so ein kleiner Junge setzt sich so vor mich, noch ein Kind und irgendwann denke ich mir, okay, das ist eine Kinderveranstaltung, ich bin hier der Einzige. Und du hast jetzt zwei Möglichkeiten, entweder du gehst, aber ich wollte das Märchen schon hören und dann dachte ich mir, dann entscheide dich für Plan B, spiel den Pädophilen, nein, ich habe mir überlegt, spiel einfach den Vater, spiel den Vater. Ich wollte gerade sagen, den musst du auch nicht mehr spielen, niemand hatte dich für was anderes als den Pädophilen. Ja, absolut. Und da dachte ich mir, damit dieser Gedanke nicht auch kommt, spielt ein Vater, also habe ich mir eines von diesen Mädchen ausgesucht und dachte, du bist jetzt mein Kind. Warum nicht zumindest ein Junge? Und dann habe ich die immer so streng angeguckt, so. Jetzt so, konzentrier dich jetzt auf Märchen. Und das Kind so, what the fuck, du bist nicht mein Vater. Und dieses Kind hat mich nicht respektiert, also so gar nicht. Und immer so, und dann irgendwie hieß es so, oh, und dann jetzt kommt irgendwie das Kamel, ganz merkwürdiges Märchen, Kamel und alle. Bin ich gar nicht, warum ist das so merkwürdig? Und so Kamel steht ihr neben und sagt, what the fuck, ich stehe genau hier. Das ist ja ein Problem. Ja, wir sind unterrepräsentiert, es gibt mehr Pferde-Geschichten. Ja, genau, und okay, manchmal Dromedare, aber was ist gegen Kamel auszurichten? Bibi und Tina auf Kamel und an Dromedar gingen genauso. Ja, das wäre eine ähnliche Geschichte. Das sind Bibi und Tina auf Kamel und an Dromedar. Und dann kam so ein Kamel und dann habe ich wirklich so gesagt so, das haben wir letztens angeguckt, haben wir auch gesehen. Und so, das Mädchen völlig in Geister, da ich dachte mir, jetzt musst du es durchziehen, du musst einfach dazwischen bleiben.
Wann kamen Vater oder Mutter, um das Kind zu retten?
Die standen alle außerhalb von dem Zelt und haben gewartet und dann kamen sie dann alle so raus und dann haben sie alle so ihre Kinder in Empfang genommen, so ah und wie war's? Und zu wem bist du in die Arme gerannt? Zu meinen echten Kindern, die mich ... Und Papa hat es Spaß gemacht.
Es war sehr unangenehm, aber ich glaube, ich habe jetzt alles, was man braucht, um Vater zu sein, böse gucken und immer so, ja, das haben wir ja letztens gesehen, also das ist alles, das ist einfach das Grösste.
Ich war einmal in meinem Leben in einem Kindertheater und dann haben die, aber das war nicht so wie bei dir, ich habe sie so freiluftmässig vorgestellt, so zeltartig, das war wirklich so ein richtiges Theater geschlossen und dann haben die halt irgendwann die Türen zugemacht, wie man das halt so macht.
Und dann geht das Theaterstück los und so und ich musste ganz dringend von Sekunde eins landen aufs Klo und ich dachte, jetzt haben die die Türen abgeschlossen und ich komme nicht mehr raus.
Weil es war für mich, es war mein erster Kinderbesuch im Theater, Kindertheaterbesuch, ich war zum ersten Mal alleine gefühlt von meinen Eltern, ein bisschen länger. Und dann habe ich einfach, weil da hatten alle so Sitzkissen und ich habe einfach losgewinkelt. Und dann so, ich stelle mir meine Eltern vor, die so, okay, haben sich aufgerafft, den kleinen Stefan zum ersten Mal irgendwo hinzugeben und ein paar Stunden allein lassen. Was soll schon passieren? Was soll passieren? Aber du hast nicht deine Hose ausgezogen. Nein. Das ist einfach, ich dachte schon so, okay, jetzt alles oder nichts. Ja, vor allem, ja, wie weird aber auch. Aber hast du es danach jemandem erzählt? Naja, es war schwer zu übersehen mit meiner Cargo-Shorts. Gott, Gottes Willen. Ich hatte dann, es war auch im Sommerurlaub, da hatte ich so eine Cargo-Shorts an, die mal beige beige war und jetzt war die halt zweifarbig. Ja, ja. Nee, ab einem gewissen Punkt denkst du dir, ich muss es gut verteilen. Ich muss es gut verteilen, damit es möglichst wieder einfarbig ist. Nee, denkst du aber auch nicht, wenn du das Konzept Türen nicht verstanden hast, dann verstehst du auch nicht das Konzept verteilen auf Hosen wegen Farbton. Oh Gott. Und dann, ja, meine Eltern haben mich abgeholt und sind dann mit mir so durch die Innenstadt gelaufen. Das war unglaublich unangenehm.
Und seitdem habe ich es nie wieder gemacht. Haha, sehr gut. Stefan Tietze, meine Damen und Herren. Mit zwanzig Jahren trocken, hat er gut gemacht. Zwanzig and counting. Zwanzig and counting. Wahrscheinlich, wie du kommst. Das ist auch meine grösste Angst. Ich habe auch keinen Vertrauen mehr in meine Blase, ich habe keine Ahnung, was da los ist. Wo hast du verloren? Überhaupt, naja, irgendwie ergibt gar keinen Sinn mehr, irgendwie, alles, was ich bei Sims gelernt habe, ist einfach falsch. Soerst ist sie voll, dann entleert man sie, dann ist sie leer. Stimmt nicht, man entleert sie, sie ist immer noch voll. Es ist einfach, ich weiß nicht, wer sich das ausgedacht hat, das funktioniert einfach nicht mehr. Und ich bin komplett ausgeliefert der Natur. Ja, das ist okay. Das ist okay. Dankeschön, das ist okay. Ich meine, der Podcast wird sich im Laufe der Zeit verändern. Wir werden älter, unser Körper zerfällt langsam, wir werden gebrechlich. Du meinst, bald gibt es mehr Pinkelpausen zwischendurch? Ja, die Folgen werden kürzer, aber dafür mehr, weil wir immer wieder raus müssen. Ich würde so gerne jetzt eine Fernbedienung haben und so 30 Jahre in die Zukunft skippen, wie dann der Podcast ist. Du kannst nur die pausieren. Weil wir machen dann immer noch weiter. Wir werden mit euch allen alt, wie Harry Potter. Und dann am Ende, ich meine, wie sieht unser Podcast aus? Du würdest allen Ernstes 30 Jahre in die Zukunft skippen. Du würdest die nächsten 30 Jahre deines Lebens einfach so skippen wollen. Nee, ich dachte, das ist eine Fernbedienung, man kann es wieder zurück machen. Nein, nein, nein. Hä? Nein, nein, nein. Aber, hä? Nein, nein, nein. Erstens kannst du nur die Zeit anhalten und dann, wenn du skippen willst, okay. Aber es ist ja keine Fernbedienung dann. Nein. Ich dachte, aber ich kann den Senderern. Was heißt Fernbedienung, wie halt so von so einem Auto, so ein Drücker. Also jetzt nicht eine Fernbedienung mit vielen Knöpfen, sondern so mit einem Knopper. Du hast nur einen Stopp, wie die Rick and Morty-Folge. Ja, so halt wie so diese Zählgeräte manchmal so, wo man so Sachen zählt, wo so jemand an der Strasse steht und die Autos zählen. So ein Ding halt. Nur falls ihr das jetzt nachbauen wollt. Falls jemand so eine Maschine hat, kann er sich mal kurz hier auf die Bühne teleportieren? In drei, zwei, eins. Oh Gott! Hi! Das haben jetzt die Podcast-Hörer nicht gesehen. Wer bist du denn? Holy! Wie bist du hier hochgekommen? Wer bist du denn? Ja, ich bin die Rebecca.
Aus Hamburg!
Aus der Hamburg-Show.
Okay, und wie bist du jetzt hierher gekommen?
Ja, ich komme aus der Vergangenheit.
Ich will meine grosse Liebe wieder zurückerobern, und deswegen bin ich hier.
Und ich wollte dieses süße verheiratete Paar fragen, was euer Geheimnis zur grossen Liebe ist,
um dann wieder zwei Wochen in die Vergangenheit zu reisen, um meine grosse Liebe zu finden.
Habt ihr eine Antwort für mich? Sie müssen sich beraten, kurz.
Rubbellose. Oh, es wird sich nervös, über die Oberstelle geschlägt. Wir wollen angenehm.
Das Vodka-Supo! Aus meiner Erfahrung keine gute Strategie. Aus meiner Erfahrung als Host keine gute Strategie. Aber ganz kurze Frage. Ja, das stimmt. Warum hat... Rebecca ist wieder weg, komischerweise. Ja, warum hat Rebecca... Rebecca hat zwei Superkräfte. Sie hat sowohl die Fernbedienung, aber, und die war jetzt hier nicht so wichtig bei diesem kleinen Skippen. Ne, man hat die nicht gesehen, die hatte die in der Tasche, die ist wirklich klein. Sie hat gemerkt, dass man über sie spricht und hat sich hergebeamt. Diese Superkraft will ich. Ich will, sobald jemand über mich spricht auf der Welt, will ich mich da kurz so, hei, daneben skippen. So ein Real-Life-Google-Alert, dass du einfach immer hörst, wenn Leute über dich reden und du einfach das mitbekommst. Willst du es nur mitbekommen oder willst du mitreden? Nee, mitbekommen. Nur mitbekommen? Ja, dann stehe ich nur dahinter und dann reden die über mich. Das nächste Mal, wenn ihr privat über Stefan Tietze redet, dann tut doch uns den Gefallen und schickt ihm einfach das, was wir über ihn gesagt haben. Kann gut sein, kann negativ sein. Aber nee, aber dann sagen ja Leute, dann sagen ja Leute, dann was für gemacht für diese Aufnahme. Ich will ja dabei sein, wenn es nicht dafür gemacht ist, dass es für meine Ohren gemacht ist. Nein, unsere Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer sind schon sehr ehrlich, ist meine Erfahrung. Okay, ja, das stimmt. Also ich wurde noch nie angelogen von einem von euch, oder? Nein, niemand, hier niemand, nein. Nein, oh, einer nickt, okay, gut. Aber das kann dieses, hast du mich noch nie schon angelogen, ja, nein, habe ich noch nicht so, ist vielleicht ein bisschen schwierig, zu schwierig für eine Kopfantwort, ist eine Wortantwort. Jonas, du hattest genug Zeit, um auf Platz zwei rumzudenken. Was ist Platz zwei der Orte, wo du dein Ticket vermutest. Papierstapel am Schreibtisch. Okay, aber alles recht nah. Also Platz drei Fensterbank, Platz zwei Papierstapel auf Schreibtisch. Wäre mein Platz eins gewesen. Ja? Weil das ist immer der Ort, wo ich alle Tickets hinlege. Und meistens sind halt keine, weil man inzwischen auch E-Tickets hat. Ich verstehe auch nicht, wie er es schiefgegangen ist, aber ... Nein, er hat das per Post zugeschickt bekommen. Okay. Okay, Stapel, aber jetzt ist natürlich das Problem, weil unser Ticket hat natürlich ein ziemlich spezielles Format. Das heißt, in dem Moment, in dem in dem Papierstapel dieses Ticket ist, ist der Stapel instabil. Es gibt gewisse Formate, die wollen einfach die Welt brennen sehen. Du weißt genau, wenn ich das jetzt in meinen Stapel mit integriere, war es das mit der Integrität. Die Statik ist ruiniert für immer. War es ungefähr, kann es so gewesen sein, und dann fällt das Ding irgendwann um, oh, das ist gut, das fällt irgendwann um, an links, und die Basis, die das Ticket ist, wird nach rechts geschoben, fällt rechts am Schreibtisch vorbei, zwischen Schreibtisch und Bett. Guck da mal nach. Wie bitte? Wie viele T-Shirts zwischen den Verlangen haben? Ah, okay, gute Frage, sehr schön. Null. Ich passe auf meine Sachen auf, im Gegensatz zu anderen nicht namentlich erwähnten Leute hier. Eine Reihe Klatsch, die offensichtlich sehr viele Probleme damit hat, T-Shirts zu verlieren. Socken kenne ich, die sind einen berühmten Socken in der Waschmaschine. Ja, ich kaufe mittlerweile auch einfach Socken monatlich, einfach jeden Monat hundert Paar Socken. Ich habe dann einfach den Kampf an ihm gesagt, er hat gesagt, wisst ihr was, ich lasse mich nicht von euch erpressen. Mir ist das egal. Ich kann euch schneller kaufen, als ihr verloren gehen könnt, okay? Ich habe diesen Materialschlag gewonnen, ihr habt keine Chance mehr. Ja, ich habe Berge von Socken mittlerweile bei mir herumliegen, aber es ist mir egal. Du kannst dich ja für Elon Musk so in diese Sockenvorstände so reinkaufen. Ich kaufe mich ein, ja. Mit deinem zehn Milliarden Patreon-Geld kaufst du dir einfach Adidas. Was ist die billigste Sockenfirma der Welt? Gute Frage. Guck mal so, kriege ich für 200 Euro eine Sockenfirma, irgendwo, bestimmt, bestimmt kriege ich irgendwas. Hat jemandste Sockenfirma der Welt? Guck mal so. Kriege ich für 200 Euro eine Sockenfirma? Irgendwo? Bestimmt kriege ich irgendwas.
Hat jemand eine Sockenfirma?
Hat jemand eine Firma, die er loswerden?
Joko hatte doch mal eine Sockenfirma. Jokos Firma. Die ist nichts mehr wert.
Ich glaube, die kriegst du einigermaßen umsonst.
Die ist jetzt verfallen so und dann überall so Plakate mit Joko und das ist dann so abgerissen und da tropft das so raus.
In diesen Büros, so ein Lost Place.
Ja, das ist so ein Lost Place, so ein Horrorfilm und dann gehen die Leute da rein und dann wollen sie das Geld suchen und dann werden sie angegriffen von radioaktiven Praktikanten oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Die schlimmsten. Die Yoko-Kalypse oder irgendwie sowas. Ist dann nicht schlecht. Kannst du einen Film ausmachen. Oder Film. Er macht da so einen Netflix-Film heraus. Ja. Und spiel mal jetzt so einen Praktikanten, radioaktivigen Praktikanten. Ah, hi, du bist der neue Praktikant sein. Ja, hey, Joko, ich hab dich gesehen bei Prosini, bei Halligalli. Wie lacht Joko nochmal? Hahaha! Wir lassen das im Zuber sein. Nach Harald Schmidt. Nee, äh, oh, stark! Ja, setz dich doch. Genau, wir suchen Praktikanten für unser Startup. Ja, also was kannst du so Besonderes über dich erzählen, außer dass du drei Arme und zwei Köpfe hast? Ja, also ich kann vier Tassen Kaffee gleichzeitig machen, ich bin radioaktiv, ich erhitze alle Flüssigkeiten um mich herum. Mega. Und ich finde richtig geil, was du bei Zirkus Halligalli gemacht hast. Also das war saulustig mit dem Porno-Pingpong und so, das war richtig saulustig. Da haben meine Kumpels und ich wirklich gelacht. Wir haben das bei uns zu Hause angeguckt und wir haben alle gelacht. Jeder hat gelacht, alle haben gelacht. Jeder einzelne von uns hat gelacht, es gab niemanden, der nicht gelacht hat. Wirklich, beide Köpfe von mir haben gelacht, beide Köpfe, wir haben uns zugenickt und haben gesagt, das ist saulustig, saulustig gerade. Müsst ihr alle gleichzeitig lachen oder könnt ihr euch individuell entscheiden, nicht so lange? Nee, ihr war ein ganz anderes, ein anderer Humor. Ich bin eher so der Louis-Diffinie-Typ und er ist irgendwie so ein bisschen Slapstick-Humor. Und der Dritte? Ja, also ich mag nur so französische Nouvelle-Vague-Filme, kann mit dem Humor der beiden anderen Köpfe eigentlich gar nichts anfangen. Okay, und wie entscheidet ihr euch, es ist jetzt nicht mehr Bewerbungsgespräch, das ist nur noch reines Interesse, wie entscheidet ihr euch jetzt für so einen Kinoabend, in welchen Filme gehen wollt?st du sagen, oder? Ah, ne, ich kann nicht ... Wir fangen erst mal ganz rechts an. Also ich mag natürlich Gaspar Noé und gerade diese ganzen experimentellen Filme. So was in der Richtung finde ich ganz gut. Und natürlich, wir kriegen zu dritt ein Ticket, das ist natürlich immer gut, sparen wir ein bisschen Geld. Ja, also ich bin eher so der Til Schweiger-Typ. Sorry, hi, ich bin Patrick. Patrick, okay. Patrick, der Gaspar-Noi-Typ heisst. Garth. Garth. Okay. Joko. Garth, Patrick. Ja, ich bin der Steffen, hi, sorry, ich bin hier reingekommen. Also ich suche nach einem Praktikumsplatz, die beiden anderen nicht.
Die beiden anderen nicht, die arbeiten in der gut laufenden Sockenfirma, aber nee, also ich schaue halt auch gerne irgendwie so amerikanische Sachen an, Anchorman oder so. Anchorman? Und ihr aber alle drei, auch der Gast bei der Typ, müsste über Pornopingpong lachen. Ne, wir überstimmen ihn meistens. Aber bei Pornopengen hat er auch kurz gelacht.
Und dann haben wir kurz gesagt, ist sau lustig gerade, ne, so? Und dann haben alle gesagt, ja, jetzt gerade ist es auch lustig. Also jetzt genau, also jetzt genau. Weißt du, du hast den Job. Ey, cool, danke. Steffen, du hast den Job. Ey, du bist echt cool, Mann, danke schön. Mega. Ciao, wann soll ich anfangen? Morgen. Okay. Wenn es dann dieses Startup noch gibt. Aber Joko's Startup. Genau, lieber jetzt gleich, sonst gleich, sonst gibt es ein Startup nicht mehr. Komm lieber heute schon an, sonst können wir es mit dem Arbeitsvertrag wahrscheinlich vergessen. Ja. Ja, das war ein Gag von vor zwei Jahren, als wir diese Tour angedacht haben. Als Jokos Schokolade auf dem Markt kam. Da war Joko, macht sein Startup. Ich bin immer noch fasziniert von der ersten Reihe, wo die Leute nicht erschienen sind. Ich dachte ehrlich gesagt, sie kommen zu spät, aber sie sind nicht gekommen. Nee, weil es ist freie Platzwahl. Dass sie noch so ein großes Tandem mit neun Leuten reinkommen, einfach so ein großes Fahrrad, einfach so reinrollen. Weil, wie gesagt, ihr habt euch wahrscheinlich diesen Bereich freigelassen, weil ihr nicht auf die Bühne gezogen werden wolltet. Aber wollen wir jemanden auf die Bühne ziehen? Ja, wir ziehen jetzt jemanden auf die Bühne. Wir ziehen jemanden auf die Bühne, denn... Und zwar, ja genau, wir haben was ganz Besonderes für euch vorbereitet, wir können es selber noch nicht fassen.
Und zwar, ja wir konnten es auch noch nicht fassen, aber wir haben es jetzt gerade auch erst erfahren.
Und zwar, am Sonntag spielt hier direkt gegenüber im Palladium Simple Minds, die Band Simple Minds.
Die man von Songs kennt ihn.
Palladium, alle zeigen woanders hin. Yes, yes, ja, ihr kennt sie, ihr liebt sie und ihr kennt mehr als nur den Song. Es ist kein One-It-Wonder. Es ist eine gute Band. Wir hatten noch ganz viele andere gute Songs. Wie zum Beispiel. Zum Beispiel. Aber es gab auch noch ihren zweiten grossen Hit. Oh ja, vor allem in Asien sehr gross gewesen. Wir hören mal kurz rein. Stark. Und natürlich dachten wir uns, hey, das ist eine einmalige Chance, die kommen hierher, die spielen in Köln, in Palladium, die müssen hier rein. Wir sind grosse Fans, wir wissen, dass ihr auch grosse Fans seid. Deswegen haben wir weder Kost... Wer hätte Bock auf Tickets für Simple Minds? Die Sache ist die... Da hat jemand Bock auf Simple Minds. Aber ganz kurz, bevor du dich meldest, und ich muss noch kurz den Kontext erklären, weil sonst könnte das schwierig werden. Und zwar, wir haben mit dem Veranstalter gesprochen, der den Veranstalter von dem heutigen Abend kennt. Genau. Und wir haben zwei Gäste-Listenplätze bekommen. Einen davon kriegt Stefan. Ja, weil ich die Band Simple Minds mag. Den anderen Posten kriegt einer von euch. Das heißt, nicht nur könnt ihr Simple Minds sehen, sondern ihr könnt auch zusammen... Wir können auch einen Awkward-Abend verbringen. Ein richtig schöner Awkward-Abend mit Stefan Tietze. Wo ich alle meine Simple-Minds-Funfacts haushaue, dass die immer fünf Minuten Terrinen gegessen haben, im Bandproberaum und so, Drogen war nicht so deren Ding. Er ist ein anderer Mensch, wenn ihr über Simple-Minds redet. Und jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, es gibt jetzt wahrscheinlich manche von euch, die sagen, Simple-Minds interessiert mich total, ich bin nicht so der Fan von Stefan Tietze. Andere von euch sagen, mich interessiert Simple-Minds überhaupt gar nicht, aber ich würde gerne mal einen feuchtfröhlichen Abend mit Stefan Tietze. Ich hätte mir eigentlich gewünscht, dass wir die Creeps, die jetzt so den Orkwood-Arben mit mir verbringen wollen, outgesourcet hätten, indem wir einfach nur fragen, wer hat Bock auf Simple-Minds. Aber da hat jemand gerade aufgezeigt. So, hier haben wir einen, und zwar, wir müssen natürlich herausfinden, wer ist der grösste Simple-Minds-Fan hier. Wir haben da hinten noch eine Meldung. Genau, können wir das Licht ein bisschen haben? Können wir mal Licht haben? Sehr schön. Wir haben zwei Meldungen, wir haben nur einen Platz für die Karte und darum müsst ihr kämpfen. Okay. Wir bitten euch beide mal einmal auf die Bühne, bitteschön. Komm mal kurz. Ja, ja, zweite Reihe. Da seid ihr, die beiden grössten Simple-Minds. Kommt gerne hier von der Seite. Ja, perfekt. Geht durchs Dunkle, stark. Einer von euch, A, wird mit einem phantastischen Simple Minds Gästelistenplatz, einmal hier an der Seite. Du kannst auch deine Sportlichkeit unter Beweis stellen, ist ein Risiko, all in. Yes, stark, stark, nehm die Treppe. Ist okay, ich hätte es auch nicht gemacht. Nimm die Treppe, nehm die Treppe, nehm die Treppe. Hey, stark. Und auf der anderen Seite? Freut mich sehr gut.
Komm gerne rein.
Setz dich schon mal auf den Einstuhl.
Hi, hallo.
Wir haben so eine große Falltür hier aufgebaut.
Setz dich einmal.
Und der, der gleiche Tickets verliert, der fällt einfach runter.
Du musst nicht so tun, als wärst du gefesselt.
Hi, freut mich sehr.
Hi, hallo, wie heißt ihr denn?
Finja.
Okay, wir haben drei Leute.
Na komm noch jemand. Warum hat er ein paar? Okay, hi, du bist auch dabei. Okay, willst du dir einen von unseren Sitzsäcken nehmen, die wir hier ... Es ist erstaunlich, wie schnell wir die Kontrolle darüber verloren haben. Wie heißt du denn? Okay. Hannah. Hannah, okay, wir haben einmal Hannah, Finja und ... Okay, Hanno. Und Hanno! Oh, Hanna und Hanno ist auf jeden Fall schon mal gut. Hanna, Hanno und Finja und Garth, Patrick und Steffen. Sehr gut. So, wir müssen, ja, bringen gerne. Das tut mir leid, dass wir keinen Stuhl für dich haben. Ah doch, es kommt noch ein Stuhl. Oh, das ist aber ein anderer Stuhl, du bist jetzt wesentlich höher als andere. So, und der aktuell Führende, nämlich Führende, bekommt immer den Liederen Stuhl. Es tut mir leid, du wirst niemals ganz dazuzuhören. Es tut mir wirklich leid, du wirst immer anders dazuzuhören. Mir tut es nicht so leid, sie ist einfach auf die Bühne gekommen. Das stimmt. Aber das spricht für mich für einen wirklichen Simple Mindset. Was fasziniert dich so an der Band? Ich habe die schon zweimal live gesehen und würde sie gerne nochmal sehen. Stark, sehr gut, die drei voll machen auf jeden Fall. Bei mir schwankt es zwischen, okay, sie ist ein Mega-Fan, gönne ich ihr, aber sie hat die schon zweimal live gesehen. Wie oft habt ihr Simple Mindset gesehen, Finja? Noch nie, aber ich habe sie bei Pitch Perfect das erste Mal gehört. Oh, okay, sehr schön, wunderbar. Und wie schaut es bei dir aus, Hanno? Ich habe sie auch noch nie gesehen. Okay, wir haben zwei zu null zu null. Können Sie selber entscheiden, wer es hier mehr verdient. Okay, meine erste Frage wäre... Also hebt die Hand, wenn ihr die Antwort kennt. Wir machen jetzt ein klassisches Quint. Genau, unser Buzzer ist, wer nimmt die Hand als erstes rauf? Und dann machen wir quasi jetzt Elimination. Ja, ja, ja. Und zwar nehmen wir die Leute, die zuerst aufzeigen, die haben dann die Runde gewonnen, wenn die Antwort richtig ist. Und die anderen gehen in die Ausscheidung, da fliegt auch noch mal einer raus. Genau. Und am Ende lassen wir zwei Leute gegeneinander kämpfen auf den Tod. Okay, ja, auf den Tod, finde ich gut, ja. Okay, seid ihr bereit für eure erste Simple Minds-Frage, die von Stefan kommt, weil der einzige ist, der sich mit dieser Band auskennt? Ich glaube nicht, dass ich mich gut auskennt, aber die erste Frage kommt trotzdem von mir. Und zwar, Frage eins, nennt einen Song, der nicht Don't You ist. Arm hoch, Arm hoch. Und sie war auf zwei Konzerten, nein, nein, nein, du kannst doch nicht dein Handy rausholen. No, das sind die Simple Minds, die haben doch nicht nur einen Song. Völlig selbstverständlich holt Hannah einfach ihr Handy raus, er muss sie kurz nachgucken. Okay, mich interessiert natürlich jetzt am meisten... Hä, aber du warst doch zweimal auf einem Konzert, wieso hast du den anderen Songs nicht gemerkt? Ich war nur die Begleitung und ich will die... Okay, okay, weißt du was, Hannah, du bist raus! Hannah, du bist raus! Hannah ist raus, tut mir leid. Hannah, es tut mir leid. Meine Begleitung hat sich nicht auf die Bühne getraut. Ah, okay, du kämpfst für jemand anderem. Alles da, okay, Hannah, du bist dabei, Hannah, du bist dabei. Aber die Begleitung ist raus. Okay, ich will auch mal eine Frage stellen zum Thema Simple Minds Band. Okay, wer am schnellsten antwortet. Wie wird die Band Simple Minds normalerweise abgekürzt? Ja, Hanna? SM. Fertig richtige Antwort von Hanna. Sehr schön. Damit kämpfen jetzt nur noch die beiden Hanno und Finja. Und da eine Frage, sehr gut, da kennt sich jemand richtig gut aus. Okay, Frage Nummer drei. Wie nennt man die Fans der Simple Minds? Die Hand ist halb oben. Und ehrlich gesagt, wer irgendwas sagt, gewinnt basically, weil ... Die Besties. Besties? Ja, das ist für mich ... Nein, das kann nicht sein. Nee, ich weiss nicht, wie man die nennt. Wirklich? Hanno, du bist raus! Riesenapplaus für Hanno, meine Damen und Herren! Vielen Dank! Was, bitte? Machen Salto, machen Salto, machen Salto, ah okay.
So, damit, nur mal aus Spaß, kannst du gleich einen anderen Song von Simple Minds anmachen und mal gucken, was dann passiert und das dann so Death Metal, weil alle denken, wir gehen auf ein Popkonzert, aber es ist dann einfach purer Death Metal. Finja gegen Hannah, ihr habt jetzt die Chance, ihr seid in der Auswahl.
Nicht nur könnt ihr einen Gäste-Listen-Platz für Simple Minds finden, sondern auch einen herrlichen Abend mit Stefan Tietze.
Hast du schon eine Idee, was du mit Stefan Tietze reden willst an dem Abend? Gut, das können wir einfach. Alles klar, okay, gut, du hast bis Sonntag, ja, Finja hat schon Themenideen. Ja, also bis Sonntag informiere ich mich auch einfach selbst über Simply Minds und dann können wir uns da aus... Simple Minds. Simple Minds, sorry, Nicht zu verwechseln mit Simply Red. Okay, okay. Das wird ein harter Abend, Stefan. Also, es wird so ein weirder Abend, weil wenn ich offen bin, ich kenne mich auch nicht so gut mit der Band aus. Okay, Achtung. Die entscheidende Frage kommt von mir. Ich bin so froh, weil mir ist keiner mehr eingefallen.
Je schneller ihr die Hand hochhebt, desto dürft ihr als erstes antworten, okay? Alles klar.
Welche Art von Musik macht Simple Minds? Welches Genre?
Ja, Hannah?
Rock? Ja, es ist Rock, völlig richtig! Hannah, du bist unsere Winnerin. Finja, es tut mir sehr leid, es tut mir sehr leid, aber das heisst nichts. Es heisst leider gar nichts, tut mir leid, Sie sind leider raus oder wir holen die Security, okay? Dankeschön, Finja, ein riesen Applaus für Finja. Bleibt mal ganz kurz ab. Ja, wir machen uns einen schönen Abend, was du gemeint. Und natürlich Hannah, die Gewinnerin Hannah. Vielen Dank. Gerne, vielen, vielen Dank an Hannah und Finja, ich wünsche einen schönen Abend weiterhin. Macht's gut, ciao. Aber Moment. Nee, ich wollte nichts sagen. Okay, dann wünsche ich dir einen schönen Abend. Aber Fl Florentin, Moment! Moment mal, ich hör gerade, warte mal! Ich hör gerade, live, wir kriegen zwei Tickets! Wir haben zwei Tickets für beide, ihr verdient sie beide natürlich, für die auch Anna. Bekommst auch noch, sorry Anna, Hanno, dass Anna dir deine Tickets geflogen hat. Wir machen das, wir haben zwei Tickets, wir haben ohne Scheiss. Das haben wir uns anders vorgestellt, vielleicht habt ihr es an den zwei Stühlen gemerkt, dass wir uns das ein wenig anders vorgestellt haben, aber ja. Wir haben wenig zwei Tickets, wir machen sie glücklich, weiß ich nicht. Ich weiß es nicht. Wahrscheinlich müssen sie das Pläne canceln, die sie haben am Sonntag für eine Band, die Sie jetzt nicht kennen. Ja. Ich werde mindestens eine von Ihnen, die auch nicht auftauchen, weil Sie in dem Freundeskreis jemanden finden, der mehr die Band macht. Ja, und ich meine, ansonsten, ich wäre auch mit dir gegangen, aber egal. Ja. Ist so auch gut, gut, dass wir jemanden gefunden haben, der die Band wirklich zu schätzen weiß. Du musst mir auf jeden Fall erzählen, wie es gelaufen ist, worüber ihr geredet habt an dem Abend. Es gibt nur eine Antwort, die ich hätte gelten lassen, weil ich sie nur weiss als zweiten Song von Simple Minds, Alive and Kicking. Das ist der zweite Song von Simple Minds. Der Name ist bis im Programm, also die haben nicht so viele Songs. Du musst bis Sonntag auch noch ein bisschen lernen, damit du da mitsingen kannst. Ich singe damit, ja, ja. Weil du kannst nicht ein simpel Mainz-T-Shirt anhaben und dann die Songs nicht kennen, das geht nicht. Das ist dann jetzt selbst gemacht, finde ich, dann ist es okay, wenn es ein selbst gemachtes Shirt ist. Ja, das stimmt schon. Die schönsten T-Shirts sind auf jeden Fall selbst gemacht. Ja. Vielen, vielen Dank, Köln. Ihr wart fantastisch, ihr wart wirklich fantastisch. Wir hatten viel, viel Spaß. Ansonsten Ansonsten wünschen wir noch einen fantastischen Abend, haut rein, wir können leider heute Abend nicht für euch Fotos machen und alles, ihr wisst warum.
Ansonsten vielen, vielen Dank, dass ihr dabei wart, Köln, haut rein, habt noch einen schönen Abend, macht's gut, wir sind raus.
Vielen, vielen Dank.
Es war Stefan Tietze und Florian Wöh und wir heben ab.
Vielen Dank, Köln!
Dankeschön, Köln!
Hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht.